alors elle était la reine du rock n'
roll vous êtes d'accord avec ça
j'imagine elle a eu cette renaissance
extraordinaire au milieu des années 80
par les modèles pour vous
Patrick vous avez raison le continent
est intéressant ne serait-ce que pour la
question musicale parce qu'elle le
servit de pont entre la musique était
limitée ou réservée aux personnes de
couleur au début des années 50 début des
années 60 et devenu une icône
multicolore comme ça aussi apprécié par
la communauté noire dont elle est dessus
que par les gens de la communauté plus
blanche et aussi autant l'icône en
Amérique qu'en Europe alors déjà ça
c'est extrêmement intéressant mais il y
a dans l'histoire de Tina Turner tout ce
qu'on veut pour étudier l'histoire de la
femme noire du 20e siècle elle est née
au Tennessee ses parents vivaient du je
pense qu'on appelle ça en français le
métayage c'est
c'est l'étape qui vient après
l'esclavage alors une fois une fois que
tu puis esclave mais tu es sur un
territoire qui appartient pas un deal
avec le propriétaire tu lui dis je vais
continuer de cultiver les étapes je vais
vous donner une partie de ce que je
récolte alors c'est pas grave c'est une
façon de dire qu'ils étaient très
pauvres comme beaucoup de femmes noires
son père disparu comme beaucoup de
femmes noires la mère a eu d'autres
enfants il y avait une certaine violence
à la maison elle est élevée par sa
grand-mère elle a appris la musique en
faisant la musique gaspo c'est c'est une
histoire qui est générale pour bien des
femmes noires mais à partir du début des
années 60 elle a une carrière qui
explose en compagnie de celui qui va
avoir rencontré à Saint-Louis Turner qui
lui rend service parce que il est déjà
lui une vedette mais il est comme
beaucoup d'hommes noirs de l'époque une
vedette qui est au prise avec la drogue
qui est aux prises avec une certaine
part de criminalité et alors ça aurait
pu être la fin de sa carrière
il faut dire aux gens
elle est battue à plusieurs reprises
elle va abandonner mettre fin à cette
relation là elle va dire c'est terminé
lui prenait beaucoup de drague il
devenait parano absolument ils ont fait
des albums extraordinaires ensemble par
ailleurs avant mais là elle décide et là
elle tombe dans l'ombre un peu
elle part avec rien les disques lui
appartiennent pas sa carrière dans la
partie pas et pendant le goûtant elle
vivait vraiment sous le seuil de la
pauvreté mais en continu à jouer moi par
hasard mon oncle Jérôme de la compagnie
dans ce milieu des années 70 le moment
où elle se cherchait et là étonnamment
des gens cru en elle elle fait une
version de Let's state together de Al
Green les gens l'ont remarqué les
européens se sont intéressés à son cas
parce que il voyait en elle une
pionnière on dit un très braiser elle
dansait comme puzzer elle a joué dans
des films elle chantait comme personne
et même si même ça chevelure dit quelque
chose parce qu'on exigeait des femmes
noires pendant les années 45 ans 60 70
quelle couvre leurs cheveux ou qu'elle
les arrange pour qu'il y ait pas de
crinière elle fait fit de ça et elle a
mené sa vie comme elle le voulait une
fois qu'elle a quitté alterner elle est
devenue organisatrice de sa propre vie
la présidente de sa propre entreprise et
contre toute attente et le une plus
grosse carrière après iTunes est devenu
méga vedette avec les succès des années
80 alors l'évolution de la femme noire
américaine c'est aussi l'évolution de
Tina Turner que 60 ans de carrière et
qui au moment où tout le monde pensait
que c'était terminé et rester en continu
d'être une grande icône de la musique
vous parlez de grands succès milieu des
années 80 quand elles reviennent c'est
un disque qui a été vendu vendu vendu à
des millions et les spectacles
oui elle vendait des billets de
spectacle elle a fait des stades au
Brésil en Angleterre en fait partout sur
la planète
alors nous je pense qu'on est dans une
bonne position pour comprendre Tina
Turner ce n'est pas une québécoise mais
quand on appelle les artistes par leur
prénom et que partout dans le monde on
sait ce que ça veut dire je veux pas
exagérer et je ne fais pas de
comparaison musculaire mais nous on a
une Céline quand on dit Céline tout le
monde sait de qui s'agit aux États-Unis
quand on dit Harrison les gens se
demandent pas de qui s'agit quand on dit
Tina personne se demande non plus de qui
s'agit d'une femme qui a qui a découvert
l'ensemble des cils de musique qui a
côtoyé les plus grands et a été respecté
par les plus grand James Brown disait
que c'était la plus grande chanteuse
qu'il avait jamais rencontré
Mick Jagger
et à chanter dans tous les domaines il
était ultra respecter 12 Grammer Worlds
des des prix de carrière de tous les
côtés et une femme qui a prouvé que tu
n'as pas besoin d'être défini par les
limites que d'autres essaient de
t'imposer mais tu peux définir ta propre
faire comme artiste mais aussi comme ça
waouh très bien dit on voit la photo
avec Mick Jagger ils viennent tweeter
mais que rien Twitter en disant je suis
très triste de constater la mort de ma
merveilleuse amie très
un talent énorme une chanteuse
extraordinaire elle est inspirante
chaleureuse drôle généreuse elle m'a
tellement aidé quand j'étais jeune je
vais jamais l'oublier écrit Mick Jagger
alors vous voyez vous avez raison
Grégory Charles David Bowie aussi qu'il
avait entendu chanté à New York avant
qu'elle revienne qui avait dit il faut
qu'elle fasse quelque chose pour qu'elle
enregistre elle séduisait on se souvient
des talons de ce petit ensemble en jeans
de ce code de Jean qu'elle avait elle a
sorcelé beaucoup de générations
et Patrice la bonne nouvelle pour les
gens qui nous écoutent en ce moment qui
ne sont plus qui ne se sentent plus
jeunes
Tina Turner était toujours sur scène à
faire des spectacles à 80 ans alors ce
n'est jamais terminé et quand on parle
de passion le mot il y a levaudé à
Patrice on est passionné de quelque
chose elle a été passionnée de musique
de son art toute sa vie et la passion sa
vie aussi des fois avec la douleur elle
a vécu la douleur pendant de longues
années et je pense qu'on peut dire
qu'elle a notre ion fait et c'est pour
ça je pense qu'il y a des amateurs de
pinaturner partout sur la planète qui ne
jure que par elle qu'on retrouve
maintenant dans des spectacles c'est
peut-être la chanteuse la plus imitée
dans le monde patr
ice Grégory Charles merci beaucoup très
intéressant de vous écouter à très
bientôt